le pire est à venir michel rocard à
arreux pire est à venir c'est
l'interview à leurs torts aux embauches
par an dans le qinghai on ne bouge pas
pendant le qinghai
[Applaudissements]
personne n'a bougé c'est parfait dès
qu'il ya un premier ministre plus
personne bouge j'adore l'interview
l'arthrose comme son nom l'indiqué
michel rocard quel est pour vous le lieu
idéal pour faire l'amour
cette cuma le lieu où c'est impossible
du coup c'est impossible je ne sais pas
en tout cas je j'ajouterais volontiers
la coucher d'un beau bateau à c'est
agréable dans la couchette dans mon
bateau alors suprême avec le ca verse
s'inverse fleet et il est tout seul avec
les dorades est-ce que vous avez besoin
de faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour besoin je sais pas
mais ça va pas mal ensemble comme ouais
un peu besoin quand même comme tout le
monde
ouais je pense pas et anormales sur ce
sujet est ce que vous préférez une femme
qui baisent bien mais qui est infidèle
ou une femme qui baisent mal mais qui
est fidèle jamais eu à me poser la
question
et vous femme qui bouge bien mais qu'un
infidèle ou une femme qui pèse malbec et
fidèle en fait il n 'ya tu préfères vous
allez au bout d'un an ça ça dépend si
c'est pour une nuit même si c'est pour
la vie michel rocard est ce que vous
préférez une femme qui couche avec un
autre en pensant à vous ou une femme qui
couche avec vous en pensant un autre
vous mettez dans un rivière que j'ai
peur rencontre et ça a dit djilla
commenté marié deux fois oui crois que
que je suis plutôt monde espérait
qu'elle pense à moi bien même si elle
couche avec un autre ça vous préférez
alors ça vous amuse mais vos impôts mais
voilà ça vous amuse toi préféré qu'elle
qu'elle pense à vous dans le couple est
ce que vous pensez qu'il vaut mieux tout
se dire ou rien savoir
c'est le dosage de l'antre 2 qui fait
les bons couples à vous pouvez gérer un
thé à cette coupe
ouais bah oui c'est pour ça que j
attends je vous fais cette interview que
vous êtes un prêt s'inscrit sioniste est
ce que vous préférez
aulas est ce que préfère être caressé
par quelqu'un qui vous dégoûte ou battu
par quelqu'un qui vous aime a battu par
quelqu'un qui m'aime attention vous
seriez un peu non donc je crois qu'on se
renseigne ici vous savez comment c'est
est-ce que vous préféreriez que votre
femme vous quitte pour un homme pour une
autre femme à partir en elle même qui
est libre à elle
ouais je suis démocrate c'est ça la
gauche peut-être il ya peut-être le pacs
est ce que embrasser s'est trompé en ont
ah bon qu'est ce que c'est que cette
philosophie que vous nous travailler
lâche ces pages vous demande mal joué
mais ça dépend du contexte et j'espère
bien que non ouais euh et sucer c'est
tromper et pardon sucer c'est tromper
non plus non plus
et pour être sûre vous ne rien rater le
in a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou